dans les années 80 les premiers français
atteints de la maladie de lyme sont
diagnostiqués dans le pays
une maladie transmise à l'homme après
une morsure de tique infectée de la
bactérie borrelia aux conséquences
parfois très graves
à l'époque le diagnostic tardif de la
maladie étaient déjà pointés du doigt je
ne dormais plus la nuit et donc consulté
deux docteurs successifs qui n'ont
absolument diagnostiqué que des
rhumatismes enfin cetera il ne savait
pas trop où j'en ai consulté un
troisième qui l' a diagnostiqué la
maladie de la m
une errance thérapeutique que certains
dénoncent et encore 25 ans plus tard
malgré les progrès de la science
c'était un parcours de cinq ans avec
plein différents tests scanner irm
j'ai vu beaucoup de spécialistes à
strasbourg à lille à paris en 2012
l'association strasbourgeoise line sans
frontières rejoint par d'autres
associations frontalière appelait alors
à une meilleure reconnaissance de la
maladie explique damon trio cela que
nous manifestons pour que notre message
atteignent largement à la fois la
population les politiques et l'industrie
shindo strictes
certains médecins prennent aussi part au
combat en 2015 ce spécialiste dénonçait
le manque de fiabilité du test de
dépistage français appelés elisa le
tester des acquis sont forts en première
ligne ne sont pas suffisamment sensible
et malheureusement il n'ya qu'eux qui
sont autorisés pour le dépistage en
première ligne du coup les médecins
passent à côté de beaucoup de cas cette
année là le nombre de malades de line
diagnostiquer et est en progression 30
3202 cas était officiellement recensés
contre 26 1146 en 2014 en 2016 c'était
encore plus près de cinquante cinq mille
cas étaient recensés sans compter les
milliers de malades toujours en errance
médicale le professeur peron en appelait
alors aux pouvoirs publics
il ya une urgence sanitaire en france
aujourd'hui c'est politique et une
décision à prendre en urgence
en septembre 2016 face à la pression des
associations et des médecins la ministre
de la santé marisol touraine présentait
un plan national de lutte contre la
maladie de lyme l'amélioration du
diagnostic et du traitement faisait
partie des priorités
mais quelques mois plus tard à la veille
de l'élection présidentielle 2017
les malades en demande est plus les
français ont le droit de savoir
les candidats à la présidentielle
doivent parler de ce sujet c'est une
épidémie qui touche notre pays ils
doivent tous en parler de temps pendant
leur campagne en 2018 en france le
nombre de nouveaux cas de la maladie de
lyme a encore connu une augmentation
significative 104 cas pour 100000
habitants contre 69 pour cent mille
habitants 2017
des chiffres qui encore une fois ne
prennent pas en compte les malades
toujours en attente de diagnostic
[Musique]